pg-13 pg-13 pg-13 don't you ever wish
that these characters could just let
loose and i don't know get a bit gritty
well i have a theory that that's exactly
what's happening right now marvel is
quietly setting up the dominoes that'll
result in their version of an r-rated
avengers a more mature cast of
characters telling scarier sexier
stories for the adult audience and it
all begins here at the end of eternals
adjust those parental settings now my
friends the mc not for all of you is
coming
hello internet welcome to film theory
the most r-rated family-friendly show
that you can find online not even joking
about that have you seen the stuff that
we've talked about over the last decade
murder but it's okay because it's being
done by kooky animatronics illegal
corporate embezzlement but don't worry
he's a vigilante with a big heart
cannibalism except everyone's a smoothie
and it's happening off-screen look it's
not just us either marvel has been
getting away with this sleight of hand
for the last decade too mass planetary
genocide that is a lot of death but it's
being done by a purple raisin man who
snaps his fingers so no biggie child
trafficking
that is a serious topic but it's being
done via montage during the opening
credits so we good fam want to spend
five minutes watching two people compete
to end their own lives when you look at
it literally that scene for the soul
stone has some very disturbing
connotations but you know it led to the
highest grossing movie of all time so
who are we to judge all i'm saying is
that the mcu has found a lot of
different ways to get r-rated content
into pg-13 packages but now the times
they are changing older more violent
marvel projects like daredevil jessica
jones luke cage and the show that shall
not be named recently transitioned over
to disney plus in a move that required
everyone logging in to set age gates on
their accounts the eternals featured the
universe's first ever round of extremely
passionate kissing and what an awkward
tonal shift that one was and with
deadpool now wearing mouse ears thanks
to disney's acquisition of fox we have
ourselves a definitive r-rated superhero
movie coming down the pipeline but i
don't think we're gonna have to wait
that long i actually think the
transition is happening now well in
other theories i've been laser focused
on the arrival of the young avengers and
a rival faction of dark avengers over in
disney plus land i think there's
something else cooking a more mature
breed of content it's a roll out that
started with eternals but kicked into
high gear last week with the arrival of
moon knight ladies and gentlemen we're
approaching the arrival of the r-rated
avengers of course they're not going to
be called that but i think i know what
they will be called and in order to
understand what dominoes are being set
up we first have to talk about blade
someone is always trying to ice skater
bill wow that was
that was a very different era for marvel
movies now it might have slipped your
mind since you know we've had other
things to worry about over the past few
years but back at the 2019 san diego
comic-con marvel was taking its big post
endgame victory lap by announcing they
plan to keep taking victory laps rolling
out literally dozens of celebrities on
the stage while announcing a whole slew
of new movies to assert their continued
domination over the box office and then
in the final minute mcu mastermind kevin
feige pulled this one out but i want to
leave you today with one more thing
ladies and gentlemen two-time academy
award winner mahershala ali
[Music]
a new incarnation of marvel's iconic
vampire hunting superhero blade why
would that be such a big deal well
before iron man and thor became
household names perhaps the biggest most
beloved marvel superhero was blade in
the late 90s this was the guy with his
movie sitting in the top 10 highest
grossing superhero movies of all time
for a solid five years standing
alongside batman and superman until he
was eventually knocked out of the
rankings by someone you might be
familiar with sam raimi's spider-man
gonna cry and let's just say that blade
was a lot more um uncompromised than his
contemporaries
are you out of your damn mind these
movies were instant cult classics
standing out for being a unique mishmash
of sci-fi horror and martial arts all
rated r and all of them pushing the
boundaries of what a superhero movie
could be but the thing is showing up
whenever marvel needs to push the
envelope that's been blade's thing since
the very beginning here's some old time
comics trivia for you did you know back
in the day you couldn't have vampires
werewolves or zombies and comic books at
all it's true in the 1950s there was a
big moral outrage campaign against
horror comics like the hugely popular
tales from the crypt series this led to
senate hearings deciding whether to ban
him instead of leaving it in the
government's hands the comics industry
established the comics code authority a
regulatory board that imposed strict
rules on anything that was going to be
published and i do mean strict under
their guidance villains weren't allowed
to be sympathetic or victorious cops
weren't allowed to be incompetent and
the words weird and terror weren't
allowed in titles at all they would have
had a field day with youtube titles
anyway these guidelines were so intense
that entire genres of imaginary monsters
couldn't even be mentioned because they
were too closely associated with no-no
topics like satanism and the occult
zombies gone vampires gone that's why
spider-man's 1960's man who turns into a
man-shaped wolf nemesis is called the
man-wolf instead of you know the wolf
man it's also why he gets his powers
from a moon rock instead of the full
moon because he is definitely absolutely
not a werewolf that would be the occult
but by the mid-1970s that comics code
authority had gone bye-bye thanks in no
small part to marvel themselves pushing
for it when stan lee wanted to run a
story about drug use in the amazing
spider-man marvel publishing who'd
already discovered the benefits of
aiming books at a more mature or at
least an older teenage audience very
quickly jumped back into the horror
comics game with grabby titles like son
of satan werewolf by night and in 1973
tomb of dracula which introduced the
world to none other than blade in all
his gory blood-soaked beheading vampire
glory so you see the pattern emerging
here right it was one thing for the
blade movies to be doing their thing
back in the 90s when marvel characters
were all at different studios and he
could do his r-rated bloody vampire
stuff away from everyone else but now
that the marvel universe is in fact a
universe a connected unified shared one
it starts to look difficult to see where
someone like blade or the punisher or
ghost rider even the grittier netflix
mcu fits in i mean urban violence and
daredevil assault and abuse and jessica
jones racism and police violence in luke
cage that's a serious problem when the
mcu umbrella has historically been known
as general audience appropriate i mean
sure a vampire show doesn't need to be
adults only but the pg-13 blade movie is
just inviting the thousand disney ruined
blade videos here on youtube with
clickbait thumbnails of wesley snipes
his headshot and a big old anime tear
rolling down his cheek it feels like
disney needs a brand for this new breed
of mature stuff a playlist header on the
disney plus feed to indicate the
adult-oriented content i mean right now
when you log on and look under marvel
you literally see everything so how do
you delineate the ask your parents
permission safe search off marvel stuff
well what about the k word no no no i i
meant knights knights silent k word get
your mind out of the gutter you weirdo
the marvel knights is a brand identity
that marvel comics has used a number of
times over the years to designate mature
audience or high-end titles separate
from its mainline publishing it's also
been the branding for a line of animated
motion comics the production banner for
punisher and ghost rider movies and it's
the book name of a short-lived unnamed
team formed by daredevil to fight
against the punisher consisting of
himself shangshi black widow moon knight
and luke cage in short the word knight
has in the history of marvel tended to
denote the content that involves its
more edgy characters and look at who
we've just been introduced to in
marvel's most recent outing moon knight
for history of moon knight he was like
blade a horror comic character
introduced back in the days of those
banned series specifically werewolf by
night issue number 32 chances are if
you'd heard of moon knight at all before
they started advertising the show it's
probably based on a series of memes that
re-edited the dialogue from old comic
battles into jokes about his random
collection of powers we're trying to
shake down count dracula for money which
is kind of a double meta joke
considering that for a horror comic
character moon knight actually didn't
have anything to do with marvel's
dracula which uh yes does in fact exist
and is just count dracula the regular
normal wears a cape sleeps in a coffin
lives in a castle in transylvania turns
into a bat and drinks blood dracula
turns out he just uh exists in the
worlds of marvel though i do gotta say
it honestly wouldn't surprise me too
much if dracula turned out to be ethan
hawk's unnamed mystery role from this
new show anyway this new series
immediately starts off showing you that
this isn't your child's superhero show
showcasing disney's newest form of glass
slipper literally glass in your shoe
giving us probably the most extreme
marvel produced moment to date he's
punching werewolves he's dealing with
dissociative identity disorder there is
a reason the show got bumped up to a tv
16 plus rating over in the uk same as
jessica jones and luke cage putting it
higher than every other non-netflix
series they've produced so far we also
know that moon knight's old frenemy
werewolf by night is getting his own
halloween special this fall just saying
between the vampires werewolves and guys
dressed like mummies looks like by the
time blade releases in 2023 the mcu will
have created the dark universe that
universal studios failed to get off the
ground a few years ago now if we were
just talking about these guys i'd be
telling you more about the midnight suns
a team of horror and supernatural based
characters that handle monsters ghouls
ghosts and were basically the avengers
for scary horror movie stuff the
original lineup consisted of blade
morbius ghost rider mordred the mystic
and eventually doctor strange with later
versions having guys like moon knight
show up as well to do whatever moon
knight decided his gimmick was that week
so there's a bunch of spooky horror
themed characters rearing their heads in
the mcu within the next two to three
years we must be forming the suns except
still doesn't explain why blade's voice
landed a coveted teaser spot at the end
of eternals sure you're ready for that
mr whitman
see this moment at the end of eternals
was weird and not just because dean
whitman here who goes on to become the
black knight and dates a character named
cersei is played by the same guy who was
jon snow in game of thrones most slam
dunk casting decision ever now the
reason this teaser is weird from a
canonical standpoint is that the black
knight and his mysterious ebony blade
isn't connected to vampire hunting blade
at all he's not one of the midnight suns
he didn't debut in marvel's 70s horror
comics like moon night there is nothing
that truly unites these two characters
except their maturity ratings you see
while moon night blade and werewolf by
night are mature for dealing with scary
monsters the black knight is kind of the
opposite he's traditionally the modern
day descendant of a renegade knight in
arthurian england who inherits his
ancestor's cursed sword the ebony blade
he then uses it to redeem his family's
name by fighting crime dressed as a
knight riding a winged horse he's not
really edgy and definitely not violence
and gore scary kind of hard to do when
you run around dressed like edward from
enchanted no the reason he's r-rated is
because his relationship with cersei
wasn't the usual cute mcu thing where
adult relationships are envisioned by
children you owe me a dance
i really like you i really like you too
i want one no in the 90s dane whitman
and cersei had less subtlety they
definitely had more of a trashy romance
novel for mom thing going on hot and
heavy hard to miss big hair big biceps
big personalities seriously though
outside of introducing the world to a
seventh infinity stone the ego stone
this slightly more steamy for mommy and
daddy reader's romance story is pretty
much the reason that either these
characters stayed popular enough through
comics most profitable period amongst
the likes of spider-man wolverine and
the punisher in a universe where
superhero relationships are typically
all high school melodrama
to realize you're waiting i would have
joined you but uh they used up all the
hot water
i should have joined you dean and cersei
came off more like grown-ups and today
these two characters were introduced
into the world of the mcu via eternals
the art house mcu film i started with an
image of a mackerel image of sand
besides a william blake poem to see the
world in the grain of sand and heaven
and wildflower hold infinity in the palm
of your hand and eternity in an hour so
there you have it theorists marvel
nights a mature line of content that'll
encompass the mcu's grown-ups division
it's a name marvel already has on file
it's one they really like to reuse and
it lines up in the literal sense with
the names of both moon knight and black
knight at least two of the guys that
would seemingly fall under said heading
it's one of the only ways to explain the
blade black knight connection that
started in eternals and the branding
just kind of fits in a more abstract way
with all the other characters who could
possibly be looped in blades got himself
a sword and deals with ancient enemies
luke cage daredevil and punisher all
love their respective protectors of the
city gates metaphors so they could fall
under the mantle too at this point when
you're marvel there's only a certain
amount of expansion that you can do
nothing can be all things to all people
all the time and there's certainly a die
hard audience for darker different
material just look at the fan base for
the snyder cut this new initiative i
suspect is their way of capturing that
part of the market too honestly i gotta
agree with kate bishop on this one your
problem is branding and when you have
such a strong umbrella brand already you
need to differentiate you need something
to communicate that these projects are
going to be a little bit different and
maybe not for everyone marvel knights
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory
and cut
[Music]
[Music]
you